now to the alarming spread of the
coronavirus over the holidays for the
past week the united states is averaging
more than 277
000 new covet cases a day it's a
battering end to 2021 forcing many
people to reconsider their new year's
eve plans nikki batis is with us nikki
what are you hearing good morning vlad
good morning well two years into the
pandemic new york state smashed its
daily covet cases record with more than
67 thousand new positive tests in just
24 hours that's a 65 percent increase in
one day the sky-high number of cases
across the country has experts urging
people to change their plans for new
year's eve
as cities prep for new year's eve
celebrations dr falchi joined other
experts wednesday urging people to skip
out on large gatherings this year what i
would suggest people do not do
is to go to very large 50 to 60 person
parties where people are blowing
whistles and all that sort of thing
and celebrating and you don't know
the vaccination status of the people in
that environment in the last week
hospitalizations increased 14 percent
with a seven-day average of 9 000 per
day with pediatric hospitalizations
being some of the most significant
increases up nearly 50 percent in
several states the surge in coronavirus
cases has pushed city leaders nationwide
to significantly scale back or cancel
new year's eve plans altogether
atlanta's 32-year tradition the peach
drop has been canceled again
san francisco also scrap plans for their
fireworks show
and while the iconic times square ball
drop will still host thousands of party
goers it will look drastically different
than past years all participants must be
fully vaccinated and masked and they
have limited capacity to allow for more
social distancing
are you vaccinated are you boosted and
have you been wearing your mask cdc
director dr rochelle wolinski advised
that even for those gathering in smaller
settings precautions are essential
ideally if people are coming together
you'd have everybody take a test before
they gather if they were intending to
take off their masks and if you have a
large gathering i wouldn't even take off
your mask in that situation despite
guidance testing is still not readily
available to everyone who wants it
leaving people facing long lines and
empty shelves
despite the record-setting number of
coveted cases dr wolinski continues to
defend the cdc's decision to cut
isolation time from 10 days to 5 days
for those infected with covid without
needing a negative test saying in part
these isolation timelines were more
realistic for people to follow
nikki thank you now